we're going to make a bit of an island
favorite and that's the mejito you don't
want to tear the hell out of the mint
we want to agitate it a bit so just give
it a quick slap over the back of your
hand because what we want to have is
that first bouquet as you go to take a
sip
i'm lynette marrero and i'm ryan chafee
wardner i think i messed up my own name
there
to me cocktails are magic and there's
something about them that really helps
bring together people in a wonderful way
i've learned how to find expression
through liquid arts so i hope you get
extremely creative the foundation for
all good cocktails comes from knowing
classic cocktails whiskey salad martini
the bloody mary margarita the
old-fashioned
understanding the balance of those
drinks is extremely important
i want to show how great cocktails can
fit into your everyday life
it's hard not to be inspired by a
charcuterie plate one of my favorite
pairings is having smoky whiskey with
blue cheese that's a great flavor
combination
bitters at the seasoning of your drink
they're there to kind of bridge all the
other flavors together and it really
acts as this kind of base in the
background of the drink really simple
but super delicious
[Music]
knowing how to incorporate eggs into a
drink safely and deliciously is really
important you have to think about it in
bakery
terms you're using something that is raw
that is getting cooked by the citrus
that's what creates that silky texture
it's not about having
crazy equipment ultimately you can make
things using jam jars or teapots or
paint brushes and chopsticks to stir
your drinks
no matter what your background is i
guarantee we will learn some things
together
there's something really fun about
getting your friends together and just
throwing this all into the mix cocktails
and bars have always been a place where
people come together to share ideas
and so we are thrilled to share our
ideas
our philosophies our sense of community
with you cheers
cheers always pleasure i'm ryan
chatham-wardner
i'm lynette marrero and this is our
master class
[Music]
you